EVERYONE, SAY IT WITH FIALA ALO.
FIALA LOST CONTROL!
FIALA.
MISHANDLED THE GREAT PRESSURE
FROM THE WILD.
INTO THE AND
WEST AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT'S
GOING ON HERE EARLY IN THE
>> Anthony: THIS A A ABOUT
HOW HARD YOU SHOOT IT.
DIDI
TURN UP, LOOKING UP, GOT HIS MIE
FIRST HOMES.
THE FIRST ROUND OF THE
SAN JOSE SHARKS BACK THE
OPEN. HIGH STICK.
IF THE STICK IS ABOVE
I THINK 65% THAT IS NO
CHABOT.
MORRIS.
POWER PLAY.
THEY
CLEAR..
ABSOLUTELY EXHAUSTED.
>> Wes: HE NEEDS A LITTLE DOWN.
>> Anthony: FROM ONE ANGLE
OTHER REPLAY WHEN YOU'RE FACING
DIRECTLY AT FRUSTRATING SHIFT F
HARTMAN DOWN CHANCES, FIVE OR
PUTS ON THE BRAKES.
AND HERE..
CHANGE.
HE'S BEEN OUTSTANDING FOR THES
DEL